event diagnose or cure any diseases as
an empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual
let's try this again hello and welcome
to daily with Doc my name is Becca dukes
and I love technology if you love
technology too and you would like to
join our team and help us with
technology I would be more than happy to
talk to you and see if you are a great
fit for our team because it's obvious I
need help I'm not afraid to admit it I
love what I do and this is like my focus
and then you get this technology stuff
in that I know how to do but I don't
love it
but yeah so welcome everybody to daily
with Doc and if you are here because
somebody invited you make sure that you
get back with them and thank them the
information that you're going to be
hearing in the next 50 minutes or so is
empowering it's something that you
yourself can do all on your own
without getting permission from
really anybody give yourself permission
to feel the difference of what it feels
like when you
give your body the 90 essential
nutrients plus if you're already sick
and allow it to thrive not just survive
because folks we are not chemical
deficient we're nutrient deficient and
when those nutrients are no longer
deficient
going into our body the body is happy
absolutely happy Dr Wallach I got a
video this morning from somebody that
I've been talking to for a couple months
and she's showing me her tingy tangerine
and she's mixing it up she actually put
it in a post that she put on Facebook
and she says I can't believe it's only
day two the difference that I feel I
didn't really believe that I was
nutrient deficient but this proves it
two days she's feeling a difference Dr
Wallach I think that's absolutely
incredible but it's it's
do I have to say it's not typical
because it really is for many many
people you give your body what it needs
and it starts to thank you right away I
know it did for me I know it did for
many of our co-hosts that are on with us
today it's just absolutely incredible
but with that being said I do have to
let you know that this program is meant
for educational purposes only on the
importance of supplementation and
nutrition and the foods that you put in
your mouth
and the ones that you really need to
avoid
are Food Supplies around the world are
null and void of minerals there may be
some vitamins there
but
minerals unless the minerals are
intentionally put into the soil that
they're grown in
there is not an abundant Supply and
there like Dr Wallach says they're like
veins of gold and silver
and that's exactly what it is to our
body gold and silver we deserve
absolutely the best
the content of this program is not to
take the place of your primary care
physician and our products are not meant
to treat prevent diagnose or cure any
diseases but folks as empowered
individuals we can choose
to put ourselves first to realize the
value that we have in us especially
mamas
we're taking care of so many people if
we don't take care of ourselves who's
going to be around to take care of them
you deserve the very best and folks
this is what we're presenting to you
today and
one of the
founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics
which if you're not familiar with
epigenetics epigenetics is this science
that proves that the previous theory of
transfer of disease that they just kept
blaming on genetics is in correct you
yourself
are empowered of what is going to happen
within your body throughout time
throughout the years if it's something
like a birth effect
so many birth defects are not genetic
they are because Mom and Dad didn't have
the nutrients they need in order to
create this human being with everything
that they need
so let's be empowered let's change the
trajectory trajectory of the health of
our communities
and just become stronger and stronger
and that includes
mental illness folks well Dr Wallach has
been studying
plants and nutrition since he was nine
he's now almost 84 years old so he's
been doing this quite a while folks
and what he has found and what he has
been teaching has changed very little
over the decades so it is my honor and
privilege to bring to you Monday through
Friday from noon to 12 50 Pacific time
again Monday through Friday
Dr Joel Wallach Dr Wallach welcome
welcome welcome to
daily with Doc well thank you so much
Rebecca and thank you team for all being
here and and for that great introduction
you've said it um all uh I just
appreciate that you have become what
should I say a legend in your own time
because you are you are getting this
information out to everybody
and of course it all kind of started
with
Dead Doctors Don't Lie and yet
depreciate that medical doctors are very
good about giving you treatments
um that very quickly relieve pain and
symptoms and people are just overjoyed
and happy that's why they've been able
to keep going for so long people love
their doctor because they relieve pain
but the disease continues to get worse
because the the
prescriptions that relieve pain don't
get rid of the disease they just relieve
pain or inflammation swelling which
gives you more function in your joints
and that kind of thing my newest book uh
the World Revolution is a 75-year
journey from five years old till now and
this just is about three months old okay
the wallet Revolution and it doesn't
have all my 600 discoveries but it does
have many of the the which they say the
more dramatic ones and then I also like
the book Hell's Kitchen okay because it
goes through the transition
through the transition from and this is
very scary it goes through the
transition
of going from
the
wood and and coal is fuel when we're
using the wood ashes and coal ashes as
fertilizer in our Gardens and the
vegetables and fruit and berries and
things are growing in our Gardens and
and grains are grown or groans we're
going to sucking up all these minerals
and to make a long story short at three
o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 Paul Paul Revere yeah
Paul Revere Town assassin pulls the
switch on the first commercial electric
engineering plant in New York and so we
named this book the Hell's Kitchen which
is a district in New York City where all
the bad things happen
and we switch to electricity and we've
built dams hydroelectric dams shut off
the flooding and shut off the renewal of
because when you would flood when the
flood waters go away would leave silt
from the mountains which were minerals
and the farmers would plow those back in
So food grown in the
bottomland were extremely nutritious and
they were renewed every year because it
would flood every year well once they
put up the dams for hydroelectric that
ended all that and suddenly now we had
all these problems we also
um what should I say you look at when
you look at Hell's Kitchen
you have to take responsibility because
the doctors are not taught to cure
diseases they are taught to make you
happy by relieving pain and giving you
more mobility and that kind of stuff and
you hear better they give you hearing
aids well why do you need a hearing aid
well you may have osteoporosis to the
skull squeezing the auditory branch of
the atrial nerve okay why are you losing
your vision well you're just getting old
I'm only 38 years old why am I losing my
vision you're getting older got to
expect that no that's because you have
obviously the skull squeezing the optic
nerve the optic art in the optic vein
and then why do you get up
three times five times ten times the
night to urinate
uh uh I I drink so much water no it's
because you have osteoporosis in the
skull squeezing the spinal cord and your
spinal cord is telling your urinary
bladder to urinate
and that's what's happening there so you
have to say okay let's sit down go
through all this
this is why we have the book
okay it's on your head this is very
dramatic because there's a CD that Becca
and I did to go along with it okay and
um
this book goes through 37 different
diseases that people get when they have
osteoporosis in the skull okay there you
go uh top skull the calvarium the skull
cab has been removed you're looking down
on the brain but the skull the skull is
only a quarter of an inch thick and then
when you go up go up there there you go
when you cut the calvarium off the skull
cap when somebody has osteoporosis of
the skull and you're looking down on the
brain you can see that the skull is an
inch and a half to two inches thick and
squeezing the
um nerves okay the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves including uh optic not empty
let's let's go to the vagus nerve
um cranial nerve number 10. when that
nerve gets squeezed you get in a regular
heartbeat and doctors say oh you have
atrial fibrillation we got to
anesthetize you cut you open take your
heart out put hot branding items on your
heart to try and find the place that's
making your heart beat irregularly it's
not a hard issue it's the skulls
squeezing that tense cranial nerve
and when you actually get that that
um uh
treatment okay with those hot branding
irons on your heart it's the most deadly
of all Medical Treatments you do not
want to get an abolition they call it
ablation you know you just want to get
that okay now thank you Rebecca all
right so
this is stuff it's written in common
lingo and then of course we have the
book you know immortality which
um goes into we spend five years
dealing with the data from long-lived
cultures why it is they live much longer
than we do why they don't have a
diseases we do they're human beings well
that's because they live in places that
have all these minerals in the soil
and their food contains these minerals
and they don't even have to think about
the hunzas and the Himalayan Mountains
their life expectancy is 120. our life
expectancy in America we're supposed to
have the best healthcare system in the
world in our our life expectancy 73 to
75 depending on Whose data you're
looking at the hunzas with no medical
doctors is 120 because they're getting
all these nutrients from the Himalayan
Mountains okay and then of course
we learned about minerals this of course
came about a long time ago when they
were using sea salt as a as a product of
cell Inland from the coast
and they were realizing that people who
had goiter for years and years and years
years they started using sea salt and
their glider would go away now they knew
it had to do with the sea salt but they
didn't know what it was in the sea salt
that made the glider go away
and so that was the first kind of
realization that there's something going
on there that we needed to pay attention
to all right and so it's one of those
things where if you do these things on a
regular basis you're going to save an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you'll save an enormous amount of money
which everything from your health care
costs to taxes and
funerals and all this kind of stuff we
spend on Alzheimer's disease very simple
nutritional deficiencies caused by
doctors 305 billion dollars a year just
to treat the symptoms Alzheimer's
disease did not exist until
1910 and medical doctors got people off
of cholesterol because they were blaming
plaque in your arteries and plugged
arteries on cholesterol so people
stopped eating eggs they stopped eating
animal fat
and they took you know Stanton drugs the
lower cholesterol and oh suddenly now
they had Alzheimer's disease and then
they had arthritis arthritis is not due
to old age is due to again nutritional
deficiencies osteoporosis due to
nutritional efficiency not old age and
626.8 billion dollars were spending
every year in America alone just to
treat the symptoms of arthritis which is
osteoporosis of your joints and we have
osteoporosis of the long bones in your
ribs and your vertebrae and that kind of
stuff your skull
we spend 2.3 to 3 trillion dollars a
year just to treat the symptoms so
combined it's over three trillion
dollars that we're spending each year to
deal with arthritis and osteoporosis
type 2 diabetes uh that's kind of wild
um type 2 diabetes we have 96 million
pre-diabetics in America
now type 2 diabetes is not a geneticism
these are not on immune disease very
simple nutritional deficiency and that
nutrient does there's actually two
nutrients involved those two nutrients
you don't find them equally all over the
world or some places where they don't
even have the word diabetes in their
vocabulary because you never heard of it
okay because they have lots of those
minerals because they live where
volcanoes pump out the ashes which have
those minerals in them okay so right now
there's 37.3 million cases of type 2
diabetes in America 11.3 percent of our
population 96 million pre-diabetics holy
moly and the annual cost for for dealing
with uh type 2 diabetes in America is
342 billion just to treat the symptoms
not prevent or cure it heart disease we
spend 316.8 billion obesity we spend 260
billion in obesity it's just a simple
nutritional deficiency causing Pica
which causes people to eat and eat and
eat and eat high blood pressure is 131
billion dollars uh Ms multiple sclerosis
is kind of a cousin to Alzheimer's
disease also a cholesterol deficiency
we spent 85 billion as when kids we
spend 80 billion we spend 80 billion
dollars a year just to treat asthma and
kids under the age of 10 in America okay
not to prevent or cure it but if you
give them all these nutrients
okay just like we do in animals farm
animals because we don't have the
ability to pay veterinarians to come out
every week and treat all the calves and
cows and so forth and so we learned that
if we put these nutrients in the animal
feeds they don't get these diseases so
that's why when I was nine years old I
realized that let's try
doing what we did for animals for people
and by golly it worked and so this is
something which is the greatest gift you
can just give to somebody is give them
these books sit down and talk with them
get them started on the program get them
started on our rebound or sports drink
with 100 nutrients in it the other
sports drinks on the market have maybe
one mineral
magnesium is usually the one that's in
there we have 75 minerals
okay and so these are the sort of things
we've spent a lot of time money and
energy making sure that we're doing
everything correctly maximizing the
benefits you're going to get
and again these things go away they're
not genetic they're not immune
osteoporosis goes away very quickly
arthritis goes away very quickly type 2
diabetes goes away very quickly I take
people that you know dialysis highly
pressure they've been on dialysis and
for high blood pressure and kidney
failure
um six days a week for ten years okay we
put them on our health demand heart pack
we give them the older daily classic
tablets through those twice a day and in
two weeks time they're urinating so they
drop their dialysis
um rate from uh six days a week to three
days a week and in two more weeks
they're totally off a dialysis they go
back to a normal life after 10 years of
not urinating and being on dialysis and
of course their analysis for three three
days a week for 10 15 years before that
okay this is very simple stuff and so
now people are losing their jobs they
don't have their Access to Health Care
insurance anymore okay and so this is
not a difficult decision to make
you put oil in your car you don't put
dirt from Texas in your car you put
transmission fluid in your car you don't
put dirt from Texas in your car you put
gasoline in your car you don't put dirt
from Texas in your car okay you put
um the antifreeze in your car you don't
put dirt from Texas in your car and so
you have to treat yourself as well as
you're treating your car and then you'll
add 25 to 50 Health years your life
you're going to save yourself an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you will save yourself an enormous
amount of money
okay and I'm going to turn this back
over to you now Becca
well thank you so much Dr Wallach that
was a lot of information folks and I
know Dr Wallach speaks very quickly
so if you're not ready to listen quickly
and if you don't write even half as fast
you may have missed a few things well I
bring extra good news because the
replays from this program are available
on YouTube go to critical Health news
make sure that you are following us
there Rumble if you're a rumble follower
follow us again critical Health news or
if you are on Facebook look for critical
health and you can follow us on Facebook
also and we have our almost all
of our most recent let's do that most
recent shows are on those three
platforms you can always go to our
website daily with doc.com
and find the replays that are going back
um it's like two years two and three
quarter years Dr Wallach that we've been
doing these programs starting out with
the askdoc live on Fridays where we did
two hours and then we've trans
transitioned into Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time if
you're on the East Coast that is three
to 3 50 Pacific time and yes 350 sounds
kind of weird but Dr Wallach he has a
schedule that is Bam Bam Bam Bam so we
have to give him a little bit of time to
get to his next program
um and make sure that there's no
technical issues getting on that one
either so with all that said Dr Wallach
we have a full house I'm excited to see
so many people here in the zoom room
with us and folks if you have a question
that you would like to ask Dr Wallach go
ahead and raise that virtual hand and we
will get to your question we try to get
all of the questions that pop up here in
the live zoom and we also go to YouTube
where people are asking questions and
then also through text messaging and
emails so there's so many different ways
to get a hold of us if you were not
referred to this program by somebody
specific and you would like to speak to
a CO health coach and you've never
spoken to one before feel free to use
that contact us on our website daily
with Doc and I will make sure that you
get in contact with one of our certified
holistic health coaches that is
available and I try to make it in your
area too so we don't have to fight with
time zones we are around the world Dr
Wallach I think that is absolutely
fabulous that we are reaching and
teaching
around the world that is so fantastic
that's one of the best things I love
about technology doc
we don't even have to get on an airplane
to do it
wow so but that takes all the fun out of
it so anyways
let's go real quick to YouTube and
YouTube we have it's kind of a
testimonial and then goes into a
question so so if I'm taking the brain
and heart pack
um and she's been taking it for two
weeks
and
I know I lost weight very quickly Dr
Wallach I lost 20 pounds in three months
this individual has lost 35 pounds in
two months and I think that is
absolutely fantastic that she is wanting
to know or He is wanting to know
um
and I'm hoping that they get back with
the person that's been coaching them and
asked them this question also but let's
get it from the man himself
how much Changi tangerine and osteopex
and EFA plus and selenium are we
supposed to be taking Dr Wallach so if
we're doing per 100 pounds
and we're looking at the brain and heart
path
just that
I'm going to say that that Foundation
that's the heavy biggest hammer in the
Box okay what are your recommendations
oh okay somebody let's just go buy a
hundred pounds of body weights they
weigh 150 pounds I just treat them as a
200 pound person okay but 100 go for 100
pounds of body weight get rid of all the
bad foods and that's where you want to
get a hold of the book uh Dr always
cooking without the bad foods 300 pages
of safe recipes and safe cooking methods
300 pages of safe recipes and cooking
methods there you go yeah it's pretty
thick yep and that'll that alone will
add many Health Food beers to your life
and then
um one healthy abandoned heart packet
has 215 nutrients in it including 115
fruits and vegetable and Berry extracts
that kind of stuff
um but it has the 90 essential nutrients
and so I want you to take half of 100
pounds a half a dose of everything in
there at breakfast have a dose of dinner
time
and then
um especially you should be exercising
that sort of stuff so you also need to
be taking the rebound or rebound uh
again
um I like the two servings a day per 100
pounds of body weight and 200 pounds of
body weight still just two servings a
day of the rebound we have the six we
have the powder we have the cans the
cans do have carbonation in them so you
do have to pop the tops the night before
you're going to drink them drink them
the next day right
and um
did you cover the efas and the selenium
let's stick with the braiding okay okay
I'm getting there I'm getting there okay
okay now the selenium
is in uh bottle of selenium is in the
potherbean heart pack but
um again uh doesn't hurt to get an extra
bottle of selenium uh I only weigh 142
and I take three selenium twice a day
okay and I'm taking two how the brain
and heart packs a month so I'm getting
everything twice a day including that
selenium
and then um when you're looking at
um
um what else did you want to know about
other than the selenium the EFS while
we're talking about selenium Dr Wallach
the selenium that you're talking about
is not just selenium no that's that's
true arsenia is a special blend of
selenium and five other cofac factors
because these other cofactors do things
that kind of assist selenium in this job
as well as do things that that deal with
problems that commonly occur Co
coexisting with Selene deficiency and so
um that's why we put all those other
nutrients in there in our selenium is
our selenium is much different than
everybody else's selenium okay
and ours is not ground up rocks okay
um
and you can read the labels and it tells
you where it comes from and so forth
very very unique stuff
but then uh again we have
um the
uh EFA plus the efas and EFA pluses okay
bfas are from uh things like berries and
and rice and that kind of stuff
and and season that grains which seeds
like sunflower seeds and so forth and
then of course BFA pluses are they come
from fish liver uh okay and we don't
like to call them oils they are
essential fatty acids oils are very
dangerous so we don't like to say oh we
have the essential oils no well
essential oils are essential oils those
are things that are aromatherapy oils
and that kind of stuff it's a totally
different category
little bottles like this that you mix in
something else and then you or you take
the lid off and just go so when you're
talking about the essential fatty acids
uh they're required for every cell in
your body to make the membranes of the
cell walls uh function properly they
also are used inside of every cell
in your body okay to support the immune
system to support maintenance repair to
support function and so forth
and some of the dramatic deficiencies of
Omega-3 essential fatty acids and omegas
of essential fatty acids or asthma and
kids under the age of 10. okay we spend
each year just to treat asthma and kids
okay this is scary 80 billion dollars in
America just to treat asthma and kids 80
billion
okay that's that's just to treat the
symptoms now that's not getting rid of
it or preventing it now this is just a
simple nutritional deficiency disease so
it's it's so important and this is why
we have the book Dead Doctors alive this
is why we have the book the wallet
Revolution this is why we have
epigenetics which is a summary
of my 5 000 page book which is in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure okay everything X my my thesis
sells for twenty five thousand dollars
each this sells for 25 bucks each okay
so most people are going to go there and
that's me a picture from Yorkies primate
Center when I discovered the first
non-human case of sizzling Bros is
supposed to be a terrible genetic birth
defect which is really just a simple
nutritional deficiency
and when I told it was a nutritional
efficiency and we could prevent this and
cure it they fired me and that's when I
went back to school and became a
physician because I knew that we were
not going to agree on that much because
they thought everything was genetic and
so
it's one of those things where
um who knows how the good Lord works and
did the good Lord
um why did the good Lord pick me to
understand physical brosis mustard this
fee we gave huh I know why why well one
of the clues is by looking at this
picture doc a lot of people say oh he
must be he's like so strict strict
strict strict but when you look at this
picture
and this little guy here who wasn't told
how to look at you and you've got that
natural connection
that's a Caring Heart that's in this
individual
and not just caring for this little
little monkey
but
everybody
who has
blood running through their bodies yeah
now that little monkey represented every
kid in the world every human kid that
had cisibrosis
okay and so that's why I was I was just
enraptured with those monkeys because
they had cisgar brosis and it turned out
that the dietitians at the Yorkies
Primary Center at Emory University had
taken away
um all of the monkey pellets because the
the you know adult monkeys were pulling
the hair on the babies and the babies
were pulling their hair on each other
and everything like that
so it took the pellets away from him
just put them on fruits and vegetables
and then they all got nutritional
deficiencies they had all these
different things going on including
scissor roses and muscular history and
so on and so
as one of those things where I was put
in a place where I was able to see
uh A system that went haywire okay they
got off the rails and it showed us
things and I was given the gift to be
able to see it and understand it
definitely a gift Dr Wallach and I love
the fact that we're continuing to be
able to spread that gift the knowledge
because
your research went beyond that lab where
you were working with those little
monkeys
it went like over 27
000 autopies autopsies worth of research
yeah and eight federal courts and eight
federal courts that's right victories in
eight federal courts that's pretty
impressive doc well let's go ahead and
go to hands and the first hand that I
see here up is Willy Willy go ahead and
unmute yourself I'm gonna go ahead and
bring you on camera here and welcome to
daily with Doc
morning doc hello how can we help you
have to speak up Willie
uh right sorry about that that's better
let's get closer to the microphone
I've got this uh dry cough in the
mornings that's persistent it just goes
on it has gone on for months and months
uh and later which lasts for about an
hour or so
and then later in the day
uh it turns at bedtime it turns to a
quite a mucousy crop just wondering
what's going on I'm on all the products
and so on okay now
um do you have any ringing in your ears
any tinnitus or ringing in your ears
I know I've got an industrial deafness
which has caused a lot of that too okay
well the reason I'm asking that is
because
the
um when you have as he approaches a
skull it squeezes the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves including the ninth
cranial nerve the glossopharyngeal nerve
was which causes problems with
swallowing taste your voice changes and
so forth and um
you have obviously approached to the
skull squeezing that glossopharyngeal
the ninth cranial nerve how much do you
weigh Willie
uh 66 kilos
66 kilos okay so you're looking at uh
uh maybe 150 pounds 150 560 pounds
something like that okay so I want you
to get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat and about rhinos no
sugar no carbonator drinks all the uh
all the that stuff's got to go and then
I want you to 160 pounds to take two
healthy pain and heart packs per month
two Health abandoned heart passion
months photos everything twice a day
then I want you to have two bottles a
month of our MSM so you can take three
at breakfast sweet laundry dinner time
and they will support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between invertebrate bone makes bone
itself I also want you to have the
collagen peptides take a scoop without
your morning drinks over their evening
drink that will be two of those little
canisters per month then I want you to
have vitamin D3 three of those twice a
day that will help you absorb the
minerals and put them in all the right
places
then I want you to use our rebound
restore strength okay you have two doses
a day but make sure
um if you're using the cans you want to
pop them at night and put them in the
refrigerator so they're flat in the
morning otherwise during the day when I
travel and during the day I want to grab
a quick one I take our our sticks
there's a complete dose of the rebound
in each stick there's 30 sticks in a box
and we have the canisters okay and let's
see here I think that'll cover a lot of
stuff
and do you have any high blood pressure
diabetes no no okay good okay we'll
start there and then give us a call
every couple of weeks and it wouldn't
hurt you know you have white hair gray
hair this is not due to aging it's due
to a nutritional deficiency okay uh you
get on our program as I've just
described your hair color will come back
I have people that you know they had
white gray and silver hair for 40 years
and in two weeks time the hair color
starts coming back and in six months
time they look like they're 20 years old
again okay so
um you do these things your body has a
capacity to heal itself
um but you do have to take these things
forever you can't just take them until
you feel a little bit better and then
you quit and then you'll be back down in
the hole again okay
okay back to you Becca all right thank
you so much Willie for joining us here
today
and Dr well like one thing that I take
because I know for myself
um with the changes of the seasons I
would get a lot of mucus and pressure in
my sinuses and I added in what uh
youngevity has and is called the
seasonal immune pack
that is absolutely fantastic I have
customers who actually work in Sawmills
who would suffer all year long
and we got them on that seasonal immune
pack and that was able to clear up all
that congestion and now is that the 90
as well as the other stuff
of course yeah so we did the 90
essential nutrients in fact
um the one person I'm thinking of is on
the brain in heart pack and added in
that seasonal immune pack with some Z
radical also and
they're like this is I I never thought
that I would be able to go a day without
feeling like I had a sinus headache
all year long okay well thank you yeah
that was a that was just a little bonus
to one of the products that Dr Wallach
may not be familiar with with all the
products that youngevity offered we have
5 000 products
well I know but Dr well like I used 25
of them on my face and in my hair
you don't use that many no and I don't
expect you to know about those so there
is one thing I'm a day late on Dr
Wallach
I'm a day late and
Marilyn not my co-host Marilyn but
another Marilyn who is watching very
consistent
um supporter of your message loves you
so much she says
please make certain he knows I sent this
message to him
happy doctor's day Dr Wallach
and that was yesterday so I didn't see
this until after the show
um but I wanted to make sure that I
shared that message from her with you
and another question that she has Dr
Wallach has to do with sciatica I know
that one
um she wants to know what could help
sciatica so if somebody's dealing with
sciatica what are the reasons that that
sciatica may be an issue okay it's
called sciatica because the sciatic
nerve is being squeezed okay the sciatic
nerve is
um the 10th cranial nerve it's being
Square squeezed up in the skull and you
have osteoporosis in the skull okay and
also you have osteoporosis of the
vertebrae okay and it's also squeezing
the sciatic nerve and so you get
um all kinds of stuff because there's
branches of sciatic nerves as it's
traveling down towards your tailbone and
so when you get sciatica usually people
get identified with sciatica when they
have low back pain issues and stuff in
their hips their legs and tingling down
on their toes and that kind of stuff and
they never relate it to the brain I
don't know if doctors do that purposely
or they're just ignorant and they don't
get taught the the anatomy okay that the
this cranial nerve goes all the way down
to your toes okay and so it's one of
those things where
and you have to treat the the
osteoporosis of the skull you have to
treat osteoporosis of the vertebrae you
have to treat osteoporosis of the hips
and the knees and and so forth otherwise
the doctors will be joyful and give me a
double knee transplant that will hip
transplant
um and that kind of thing cut your legs
off give you an artificial limbs and so
forth and really it's just osteoporosis
of the skull squeezing that tense
cranial nerve
all right and I know that squeezing
because when you people don't think
about referred pain
I mean that squeezing is somewhere other
than where the pain is that's correct
ing the nerve as the nerve is coming out
of the skull but you're feeling it down
on your lower back
or down through your shoulders into your
fingers and your wrists and your ankles
and your knees in front of your knees
down your buttocks
yeah that sciatic those sciatic nerves
and all of those nerves throughout the
body
um
you either love them or hate them doc
yeah they're the branches of the sciatic
nerve of course that sciatic nerve Go is
is a branch of the
um
the the 10th Trail nerve okay the vagus
nerve the same vagus nerve causes
the heart to beat irregularly atrial
fibrillation and so you got a heart
thing going on high up
swallowing problems and the ninth
cranial nerve okay
glossopharyngeal nerve all these things
are going on because of osteoporosis and
you're going to
um ear nose and throat doctors you're
going to Joint Specialists and
everything they're giving you
painkillers and crutches and all this
kind of stuff but they're not getting
down to the Nutritional deficiency cause
of the issues
okay because if everybody were taking
all the 90 essential nutrients
how many knee replacement surgeries
would it be none
how many kids not go to college because
their their parents couldn't afford to
send them to college because they don't
have all those surgeries to do
huh
well Dr Wallach I know what we're doing
can make a huge impact in the world so
let's just keep on doing it let's keep
on doing
another oh 60 years at least
well so Usher has a question and and it
refers to something that you mentioned
mentioned in the opening she said if
frequent urination is not related to a
lot of fluids that you're drinking each
day then why
would somebody have to frequently
urinate if they don't have the fluids in
them to get out
why would they have frequent urination
again because the skull is squeezing the
spinal cord and the spinal cord is
telling a urinary bladder to urinate and
the urinary bladder tells you to urinate
you urinate and
um this causes all kinds of stuff
because you're losing more nutrition
every time you urinate you're getting
dehydrated and so forth and just
drinking water will not replace all the
mineral elements you're sweating out and
urinating out okay so your your reserve
of elements in your body are going down
down down down down down down so not
only is getting up
three five eight ten times an idea and
eight or that happens during the day too
okay gosh every hour seems like I need
to run to the bathroom that's because
your skull is squeezing okay
um the spinal cord and the spinal cord
is telling your urinary bladder to
urinate and they're trying to kind of
been in a certain position you put
pressure on that oh I gotta run to the
bathroom and then you'll you know I
better have some water here you drink
more water but are you getting more
minerals no unless you're consciously
proactively supplement you're not
getting you're not replacing everything
you're urinating out and so this is why
people when they have these issues
You can predict then three to six months
or a year later they're going to have
some catastrophes happening okay
fractures are really severe problems in
their joints and so forth that you're
begging the doctor to give you an
artificial knee or something okay it's
one of those things and so these things
occur
not by accident not by genetics not by
own immune they're caused by
deficiencies
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and a quick question from Jill
she says can we recommend
um for somebody or what can we recommend
for somebody who has swelling under
their eyes all the time
so I don't know if that's like puffing
just
frequent puffiness or if it's like bag
swelling type thing
um
so I know that there's a lot of things
within the body like the lymphatic
system that can get plugged would that
cause
that could be the lymphatic system it
could also be the
um again the skull squeezing
the cranial nerves the facial nerves
okay that kind of stuff the optic nerves
the optic artery the optic vein and the
optic nerve gets squeezed by the skull
and you have osteoporosis and causes all
that swelling around the eyes it can be
fluid it could be just a puffy once I'd
say not fluid necessarily but it could
be just a baggy skin
okay because not having all the
nutrients for the elastic virus that
tone up their skin or it could be that
again the arteries in the veins are
being squeezed by the skull the optic
nerves the optic artery the optic veins
so that the circulation around the eye
as well as in the eye is going away and
so that's why all this eye stuff is
going on
so this is these are red warning lights
on the dashboard you just can't say look
in the mirror say oh gosh I guess I'm
getting old and just forget it you got
to really get on these nutrients get off
the bad stuff
and pay attention here and start looking
for the other things because the other
things will pop up
um they may have already popped up
you're not paying attention to them so
you need to sit down and go down the
list and say do I have this so I have
this so I have this oh yeah I have three
of those things and I didn't even pay
attention to them and so this is why we
come up with these books and CDs and
DVDs
because
um we can't be everywhere
and you have your circle of
family and workmates and Associates and
church mates and so forth and so we knew
in the beginning they were going to have
to raise an army of people that got the
same
access to the same information same
knowledge and the same supplements and
so that's why we came up with all these
books and CDs and DVDs and so forth and
lectures and now it's a blessing they
have all this technology now I mean
um yesterday I was in the Philippines
today I'm going to be in Australia
yesterday Dr well like you were in the
Philippines and in California and in
Michigan all at the same time well there
you go
there you go and so so you know we're
doing what we can do and so we're
looking to build an army and we pay very
well and so you know if a few extra
bucks can help you the tax deductions
um you know off their square footage
you're using out of your house whether
you're renting or buying uh the same
thing that that same percentage off your
utilities and so on you get a lot of tax
breaks when you run a youngin business
out of your home you get a lot of tax
breaks and you'll get if you're if
they're withholding taxes from you
because you're working someplace and
there was holding taxes and giving to
the
um IRS who get a lot of that back at the
end of the year when you do your taxes
because you have all this these records
of everything that you're spending okay
to run your business out of your house
you know your your office your Warehouse
your meeting room your utilities and so
on there you go in your own personal use
of products so those can all be part of
your business plan that your younger
business is going to pay for your
supplements okay and so forth and then
it becomes tax deductible
yes it's it's pretty nice folks it
really is and you can get Dr wallach's
books which are resources that I use
every day knowledge that got me started
that his books are also part of the
curriculum of the health coach
certification course that's offered by
The Institute of holistic health so if
you are interested in learning more
wanting to get deeper into the four
areas of Health how they're affected by
minerals
deficiencies and non-deficiencies then
you might want to check out the
Institute of holistic health certified
holistic health coach program you can go
to
coachwithbecca.com and get more
information about that but if you were
referred by somebody's specific get back
with them ask them if they know about
the health coach certification course
and they may have their own link to
share with you that gives you
information as well so Dr wellick we're
coming up real close to the end of our
time with you and Kathy has a question
here Kathy go ahead and unmute
hello Kathy how can we help you
oh I want to know
I I
um
I look like is is it is it okay to drink
milk
I'm sorry I missed that is it okay is it
okay to drink milk
oh yeah milk milk is one of God's
greatest Creations
um every mammal whether an elephant or a
walrus or a whale or a human being or a
monkey or a buffalo or a wombat or a
rabbit every every
um
um mammal vertebrate mammal okay uh it
uses milk to raise babies
perfect food I'll repeat that milk is
the perfect food and so there's nothing
wrong with drinking milk when you're 200
years old okay nothing wrong with that
all right thank you so much for that and
we do have several hands up Dr Rolex
let's see if we can get one more real
quick yeah we got to do a quick one one
more
do you have a quick little question for
Dr Wallach
yes hello uh from JD man in the chat he
said are there guidelines as to when to
take supplements such as in the morning
the evening with or without food are
there guidelines
uh the guideline is you take your
supplements with food and whatever your
dose is I prefer you to break it up so
you're taking half your dosage of
breakfast half your dosage at dinner
time if you're a 300 pound 400 pound
person you're gonna be taking it three
times a day you'll take a third of your
dose of breakfast or your dose at lunch
until your dose at dinner time don't
take it all at once okay you want to
spread it out and you want to take it at
the beginning of each meal you take a
few bites of food get a little food so
you start with your digestive enzymes
and all that kind of stuff happening uh
the process of digestion and so then you
start taking your supplements uh don't
don't take them you know in between
meals don't take them before you go to
bed that kind of stuff you take them
with your meals okay
so all right thank you thank you so much
okay
okay I apologize I do have to run you do
have to run Dr Wallach so thank you so
much again for joining us here on daily
with Doc today folks Dr Wallach will be
back on Monday so make sure that you
come back and visit with us as well
Monday if you have questions oh
I love whenever it hits the wrong button
but if you have questions that did not
get answered today you can always go to
daily withdoc.com we do have that
contact us option there you can submit
your questions there
um
and we have a team of certified holistic
health coaches that are going through
and working through these these
questions as they come in one by one and
we try to get them in the order that
they were received so if I could get my
co-hosts on with me and Farhan I know
you had your hand up I'm sorry we didn't
get to the question that you had today
well we have Marilyn pazera spear we
have Farhan Nasir and also Ruth Ellen
Sanchez as our co-host today I could not
do this without them and I love the fact
that they have have volunteered to use
their skills to help make this program a
success and again if you have skills
that you would like to contribute to
a great purpose in getting information
out around the world
get back with the person that invited
you to this program if there's nobody to
thank go to our website daily with
doc.com use that contact us and let you
know let us know that you have skills
that you would like to put to use for a
greater purpose and until next time
and well even now my name is Becca Dukes
I'm so excited to have you here with us
each and every day hello to those of you
out in YouTube and Rumble and Facebook
go ahead and put your comments in there
as well because we do have people that
help monitor those comments and get
questions answered but the best way is
through our website
baileywithdoc.com until next time bye
for now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]